this video is sponsored by inog are you
ready for the next transit
[Music]
Revolution this is not a car this is not
a car this is a vehicle level five
autonomy level five autonomy scalable
scalable the new Robo taxi from zuk's
owned by Amazon wow what the is this the
solution to our traffic problems will
Amazon I mean zuk I mean Amazon
revolutionized trans it in our cities of
course they won't this is an incredibly
stupid impractical and dangerous idea
it's so dumb in fact that even Elon Musk
came up with it some time ago so what's
wrong with this project what is wrong
with flooding cities with autonomous
pods owned by Amazon to solve traffic
let's find out their stated goal with
this project is surprisingly Progressive
they want to change Americans attitude
towards car ownership personal car
ownership something that is ingrained in
the psyche of this nation and we're
challenging that openly and proudly
because we think that the benefits for
society and every single one of us
outweigh the oh well you know I want to
be able to have as many cars as I as I
want or as I feel like the idea is for
people to not have to own a car because
they'll have access to Quality transit
in the form of their Robo taxis and this
is all well and good but we're talking
about Amazon here and when giant
corporations offer to make your wishes
come true you better be careful chances
are it's not a wish granting Genie but a
monkey Spa available on Amazon for 1872
in popular culture the monkey Spa is an
item that will grant you three wishes
but with unexpected horrifying
consequences as punishment for tempering
with fate so we wish on Amazon to fix
traffic in our cities what could go
wrong with that what could go wrong with
putting Amazon in control of our Urban
transportation in the zuk's promotional
material they say that you won't have to
buy a car yourself you'll just have to
pay for the individual rides and the
city would be full of autonomous zuk's
taxis constantly circulating so he can
just order one at any time this would
free up a ton of space currently used
for parking lots and we could have
narrower streets more parks and so on so
the wish is made the monkeys SP curls
and Amazon now owns every single vehicle
in your city but rides are super cheap a
bit too cheap so cheap in fact that
every other Taxi and public transit
service gradually goes Bank craft and
out of business giving Amazon a complete
Monopoly over Transit once that's done
they can hike the prices back up even
higher than what the competition used to
offer while they existed so now Amazon
can turn massive profits this also poses
problems with social accessibility in
the material they stress how they want
to serve underprivileged neighborhoods
currently not served by public transit
transportation is a big deal in terms of
access to knowledge access to Freedom
Independence and just things there are
areas right now that have not served
well our goal and this is something
that's particularly important to me is
for this vehicle to go to all areas of a
city and this sounds very nice but there
is a problem a massive contradiction in
the form of Amazon wanting to provide a
public service while also being a
profit-oriented corpor operation and you
can't have it both ways here it's one or
the other see a big reason why
enterprising businessmen tend not to set
up transit services in disadvantaged
areas is because there is not much money
to be made there revenue is lower crime
and vandalism are a bigger problem and
so on and cities usually solve this by
cooperating with police and social
services having security Personnel Ride
Along on riskier routes tweaking street
lights to eliminate dark areas around
stops putting up cameras getting rid of
bushes so that no one can jump you at
night there are many ways to help
disadvantaged areas get a practical and
safe Transit service and Amazon has
absolutely no inclination or obligation
to do any of them nor do they have any
to safeguard your personal data thank
God that incognit is sponsored of
today's video protects your privacy by
reaching out to Holders of your personal
information like Jeff Bezos on your
behalf and requesting their removal okay
maybe they won't be writing to Jeff
basos himself but you get the idea this
personal data ranges from your full
legal name phone number date of birth
home address or even patterns of
movement in your city the process of
removal is fully automated unlike
robotex once launched it does not
require any further input from you
unlike Robo taxis incog will be dealing
with holders of your personal
information on your behalf this is to
prevent you giving out your contact
information somewhere for it to get sold
off so you start receiving unwanted
marketing or even scam calls or someone
orders 50 Robo accxes to your house in
the morning to sabotage your commute or
if some website with your personal data
on it gets breached that someone takes
out a loan under your name and identity
that's not good this is where incognit
comes in or other before all this
happens by handling personal data
removal on your behalf first create an
account and specify whose data they'll
be requesting to remove second you
granting the permission to act on your
behalf they'll be contacting holders of
your personal information to get it
wiped from their databases third kick
back and relax something you would never
dare to do in a robo taxi and watch
incog handle all that work for you
you'll be able to keep track of their
progress live on their website don't let
your personal data get into the wrong
hands the first 100 people to use the
code something at the link below we'll
get 60% off incog thank you for checking
out incog they help me pay my public
transit pass now where was I right so
what would end up happening is the zuk's
robo taxes are sent out across the city
where in the rich areas they turn a
consistent profit but in the poor areas
Revenue would be lower and the cars
would constantly get smashed up
graffitied equipment would be stolen and
so on at that point Amazon would just
start blacklisting neighborhoods and not
run any Services there so you know dear
residents of District 12 due to recent
vandalism to a robo taxis your district
will be deprived of Transit as
collective punishment best of luck
getting to work the thing is these cute
Sleek modern Robo taxis are well suited
for safe upper middle- class
neighborhoods where everyone travels in
clean dry clothes all the time there is
virtually no crime the roads are smooth
and properly signposted as soon as you
go below that you start having problems
for example there are so many creative
ways to rob people in this thing on a
tram or a bus robbing people is
difficult the lines usually go along
busy areas but it's hard to disappear
the driver might call the police and try
to lock you in but most importantly
other passengers will likely try to stop
you or run after you sharing your
location with the police in the zuk's
robo taxis all you need is two of your
buddies who are in on the plan the three
of you get in next to an unsuspecting
passenger then when the time is right
take everything they have at knife Point
pry open the doors and run off into the
night or if that's too risky you can
just wait for a single passenger Robo
taxi to pass a badly lit area where you
roll out a trash container or something
in front of it when it stops you can
just run up open the door with a crowbar
and drop the passenger at gunpoint would
Amazon then invest into unbreakable
glass prying resistant safety doors the
security detail to monitor risky areas
of course not they would just stop
running Robo taxes in poor areas because
that's the most financially sound option
so from a social perspective the zuk's
robo taxi is a complete failure in the
US they would basically become the white
middle class Express in a spectacular
return of corporate en forced
segregation and that's simply because
Amazon does not care about public
services or social equality like all
corporations they only care about
money and if the crime problem wasn't
bad enough already we haven't even
talked about acts of vandalism and
sabotage what if you order a taxi at 2:
a.m. and find that the person before you
threw up on the seats what if someone
lets their dog inside every Robo
taxi they travel in what if you wait 20
minutes for your robot exit to show up
and then find the seats dirty wet
covered in glass shards and so on you'll
likely be able to report the problem and
send the car back to the depot or
something but then you'll have to wait
another 20 minutes for the next one what
if that won't be clean either better yet
what if people deliberately sabotage the
system by flinging dirt into the
passenger compartment when the doors
open throw rocks at it damage the
cameras on top puncture the tires when
they're charging on the street start a
fire under the battery compartment once
Amazon sweeps through the area I imagine
there will be plenty of former taxi
drivers and public transit employees
eager to express their opinion of Amazon
in very practical and creative ways also
the robo taxis will inevitably be used
as board movies sense just something to
keep in mind if we're being realistic
this Robo taxi system just won't work in
the real world come to think of it it's
a prime example of elite projection the
belief among relatively fortunate and
influential people that what those
people find convenient and attractive is
good for society as a whole the zuk CEO
Aisha Evans can talk about accessibility
and equality all she wants but she's not
like you or me she's part of the West
Coast Corporate managerial class raking
in six figure salaries and apparently
seven figure bonuses and would you look
at that this millionaire corporate
manager thinks the future of
transportation is putting everyone
inside tiny rolling VIP lounges another
aspect the Zuko taxi fails at is
scalability I know they say scalable in
the beginning but that's just not true
like with all futuristic
Transit ideas these things can transport
a very small number of people four
passengers in this case which is less
than the average car and this is a
problem think of morning rush hour where
hundreds of thousands of people are
trying to get into the city within a few
hours in Budapest for example the M3
Metro alone has 400,000 passengers
boarding it on every single workday
let's assume it breaks down to 200,000
in the morning and in the evening now
let's take these zuk's Robo taxis let's
suppose an average occupancy of two per
vehicle by contrast the average
automobile occupancy is 1.5 so we're
being charitable so in order order to
move 200,000 people to work in the
morning the robo taxis would need to
make 100,000 trips let's say they have 3
hours to do so between 6 and 9 a.m. with
the average trip taking half an hour so
assuming no delays or complications one
Robo taxi could make six trips every
morning so to have the same passenger
capacity as a single metro line in
Budapest you would need more than 16,000
Robo taxis circulating in just this
single Direction and The M3 Metro isn't
even the largest operation with its
400,000 passengers the tram network
carries 930,000 ,000 and the bus Network
1.2 million and Budapest accomplishes
this with 1,00 buses 320 TRS and 75
Metro trains now compare this to the
16,000 Robo taxes needed just for the M3
line now that's what I call scalable
let's also talk briefly about
self-driving in their promotional
materials they state that the think has
level five autonomy their evidence for
this they self certified
it that's very reassuring so what's next
we're looking forward to our next step
of obtaining a permit to operate our
purpose built vehicles on public roads
in California and if you've been reading
the news at all self-driving cars on the
roads of California have been a great
success so far and by that I mean a
Non-Stop disaster show you've probably
seen them on social media videos going
viral of driverless taxis in San
Francisco causing traffic jobs this is
where our countryes come to and as the
frustrations grow the oversight seems to
be on its own jerky ride this level five
autonomy is some clever piece
of marketing from zuk's level five impli
some advanced technology never before
seen in reality level five just means
there is no steering wheel or pedals
making the vehicle potentially fully
autonomous since human physical input is
impossible that doesn't mean at all that
the vehicle can actually safely
self-drive but apparently neither zuk
nor San Francisco cares and no driving
around an empty parking lot half of it
while using a controller is not an
impressive engineering feat I don't
think we will ever have full
self-driving to be honest I don't think
it's possible our roads are just too
complex there are too many variables
obstacles situations which is something
you cannot really prepare a program for
zuk's solution to this is to just use
their cars to map the entire city this
is a far cry from an advanced algorithm
prepared to respond to any situation
this is just a GPS system with extra
steps and we already know how well that
works all right I've been criticizing
zuk for a while now so in the spirit of
fairness I'll now offer some suggestions
to help fix the shortcomings of this
system the way I see it zuk is set to
operate in two main environments dense
urban areas and more spread out Suburban
areas in dense urban areas we run into
the problem of scalability as we've seen
before so what if we somehow made the
robo taxis bigger Longer added more
doors and more seats and a bigger engine
so we can transport more passengers at
once we could run these Mega taxis on
predetermined lines which could create a
dense web across the city providing
equal service to everyone since we're
following predetermined lines we could
even get rid of the large and heavy
battery and put up some wires above the
roots on busier lines we could even put
the mega taxis on Rails to reduce
friction so we can make them even bigger
into Giga taxis on the busiest roots we
could even put them into tunnels on
fully dedicated Express lines and make
the vehicles even larger so the
Subterranean Terra taxis will be able to
accommodate vast numbers of passengers
we could then run these lines all the
way into the suburb so people can use
them for their commute so this leaves us
with the Suburban zuk's Robo taxis our
task is to get people to the mega Giga
and terot taxi stations but here we
encountered the problem of safety and
vandalism since the distan has traveled
here are relatively smaller and the
streets are generally calmer I propose
shrinking down the Duro taxi
significantly make it single seat get
rid of the roof and windows have it roll
on two wheels and let passengers control
it manually I also propose a chain
operated pedal based mechanism for
manual propulsion the engine battery and
self-driving systems are now unnecessary
we can get rid of those to cut costs
there you have it our affordable two
wheel individual light taxis is complete
ready to connect you to the network of
Mega Giga and terot taxis and I'll be
hurrying to the pant office with these
so that no one will be able to steal my
genius ideas never before conceived of
by Humanity thank you for watching it
feels good to have once again solved
traffic and don't forget the first 100
people to use the code something at the
link below we'll get 60% off inog so do
check it out big thanks to incog for
sponsoring today's video and I'll be
seeing you next
time